-Our next guest is a very
talented comedian and actor
you know from shows
such as "Detroiters,"
"Veep, and "Ted Lasso."
He stars in "The Afterparty."
New episodes are available
Fridays on Apple TV+.
Let's take a look.
-I look at that picture,
and it hit me.
[ Thud ]
[ Grunts ]
[ Tires screech ]
-[Bleep]
Holy [bleep]
Are you okay?
Don't be dead.
Hello! Aniq?
-Oh.
-Here we go. You okay?
-I think I swallowed a molar,
but I'm fine.
I'm fine.
I got to get to that party.
-No, no, we got to get you
to a hospital, okay?
-No.
Ooh.
Zoe and me, we had a moment.
We almost kissed.
-Oh, that's --
see, that's incr--
It almost makes you forget
that you just got run over
by a car, right?
-Please welcome back to the show
Sam Richardson, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you?
-I'm so good.
I'm very well.
-Welcome back to the show.
This is a fantastic premise
for a TV show.
It is an afterparty
at a high school reunion,
and someone's been murdered,
and each episode shows it
from a different perspective.
It's got
a fantastic comedy cast.
It must have been
so much fun to do.
-Oh, it's so much fun.
I mean, from top to bottom,
you know, Tiffany Haddish,
Ben Schwartz, Ilana Glazer,
Jamie Demetriou,
just wall to wall.
Everybody in this thing
is the funniest, nicest,
best person to work with,
so it just kind of made it
just a joy and delight
to go to work every day.
-And especially to make --
anyone making comedy
during the pandemic,
which was a time
that was so lonely,
to be able to get together,
obviously on a very controlled,
very safe set,
to be with comedians again
must have been great.
-Very safe.
We tested twice every day,
a rapid test and a PCR test,
and then we'd test on Sundays,
so it was very safe.
And then when we're on set,
it was so crazy
to, like, take your mask off
and then perform a scene.
You're like, "Oh, my God,
is this real life?"
But, like, in this real life,
somebody had been murdered,
So it was a little bit of --
-Yeah, yeah.
You're like, "Would I trade
a murder to not wear a mask?"
-Hmm.
Am I the one who's dead?
-Hey, your co-star
Ike Barinholtz and our friend
was here on Monday,
and he left a signed headshot
he wanted me to give
David Letterman yesterday.
I didn't.
-Uh-huh.
-But he wrote, "Dave,
thanks for all the laughs.
Ike Barinholtz."
Would you like it?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, you don't have
anything else to do with this?
-Nothing.
-It's got plain paper
on the back, though, yeah?
-Oh, yeah,
I could use it for notes.
-Yeah, use that for notes.
-Thank you.
-Yeah, of course.
-You're really good at this.
-I'm good at problem solving,
you know.
-I mean, I was like, this is
just going to be garbage,
but now it's useful.
Have you -- You know,
the premise of this
is people getting together,
old high school people.
Have you gone to high school
reunions of your own?
-I haven't.
This year would have been
my 20th reunion.
-That's a good one.
-Yeah.
I figured that would be
a really great one,
but I've always missed,
and this year I would have liked
to have gone,
because I think
I would want to go
and just, like, be a full, like,
movie star.
-Yeah, this is the year.
-And just, like,
wear sunglasses throughout.
Back in Detroit, like,
"What's going on?"
-I can't imagine Detroit
would treat you very kindly
if you behaved that way.
-No, no.
It's a real humbling place.
Like, "What are you doing?"
Like, "Sorry.
I had cataracts."
-You also -- Is it true you did
Model U.N. in high school?
-I did.
-So they would have been excited
to see you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah, alright.
-Yeah, a lot of U.N.-ers.
-A lot of MUNers.
We call it MUN.
-Do you think they would be
disappointed to find out
you weren't in the actual U.N.?
-Yeah, probably.
-Yeah.
-I'd be like,
"I'm working on it."
But, you know,
I was in Model U.N.
I was in debate,
I was in a lot
of extracurriculars.
But I was, like, a bad student
and, like, didn't really
work hard at stuff.
So, like, in Model U.N.,
I was always Ghana,
'cause my family's from Ghana,
and I would be like,
"Yeah, I'm Ghana.
So what's the resolution?
Yeah, Ghana agrees.
Sure."
-So your heart wasn't in it.
-No. I just liked to hang out,
you know?
-Well, that's nice.
That's a nice group of people.
The Model U.N.-ers are
a nice group of people
to hang out with.
But you did have politics
in your family.
Your aunt was a member
of Congress, elected in 1990.
-Yes, the first black woman
to be elected to Congress
in Michigan.
-That's amazing.
-Yeah.
-And your dad
worked on her campaigns?
-Yes, my dad
was her campaign manager,
and she just passed in November,
so rest in peace,
Auntie Barbara Rose.
But my dad was her campaign
manager, and I was young,
so I would just be around
the meetings in the office,
but, like, I wasn't
paying attention.
I was like about 7, 8.
You know, so I'd be --
[ Laughs ]
I was just, like,
a real distraction.
Like, one time I had --
I would just, like,
listen to music.
I had this boom box
and I'd play this tape,
and it was the Chipmunks
singing "Bette Davis Eyes."
-Oh, yeah.
-And I'm just, like, there --
"Ooh, she'll take you
on the floor."
My dad was like, "What is that?"
He comes in like,
"What is this thing?"
It was too late.
It was already in my head.
-Yeah, but those were the seeds
of politics
that brought you
to the Model U.N.
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
Did Auntie Barbara Rose
watch your work?
Did she watch "Veep,"
for example,
which was, you know,
a show that everybody says
is the most like politics?
-You know, if she did,
she didn't talk about it a lot.
-Uh-huh.
-One of my first
television gigs was,
I had a recurring role
on "The Office,"
and my family had,
like, a viewing party.
-As they should.
That's very sweet, supportive.
-Very sweet. At my
Auntie Barbara Rose's house.
And so everybody went.
They watched the episode.
And I saw her after, and she was
like, "I saw your episode.
You were hardly in it."
I was like, "Well, yeah,
it's my first one.
I don't just start at the top,
you know?"
-Now, the first time I saw you,
you were on main stage
at Second City in Chicago,
but you had done
Second City Detroit.
You had also done
Second City touring.
For people who don't know,
this is sort of a touring troupe
of improvisers that play venues
of all sizes, of all types.
What were some
of your weirder gigs?
-There was some really fun gigs.
You know, you're playing
in opera houses.
It's like,
oh, what a great audience.
Then there were
some really trash ones,
like this one,
we were performing improv
for a marathon.
So...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
As confused as you are,
so were we, you know.
-But wait.
Would you have to run alongside?
-That would make more sense.
-Okay.
-But we're just on this stage,
and the people are running past,
and we're performing, like,
improv games and stuff.
And, like, there's no way
you're going to get
the full thing of that.
Like, you're either
at the beginning
or the end of whatever joke
or bit you're doing.
So it's like, "And that's how
they called them Slappy."
And they're like,
"What does that mean?"
"Welcome to my office. I'm --"
And then that's it, you know?
-So it was really only good
for very slow runners.
-Exactly, the ones who are like,
"I think I'm done.
Oh, comedy.
Very good."
-Now, did you have
a Disney World gig?
Or did you just aspire
to have one?
-So I aspired to have,
but then I went to --
I worked in Disney World
in the college program.
I went and did the college
program in Walt Disney World,
and I ended up working
in Animal Kingdom.
-Uh-huh.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah!
Animal Kingdom, stand up!
Whoo!
My animalites are here.
I worked on Dinosaur the ride.
-Alright.
[ Applause ]
-Whoo!
Dinosaur-heads, stand up.
The dinosaur people are here.
But it was a wild time,
like, altogether,
because it was a college
program, so all I had to do
was just, like, live in these
apartments that they had for us,
and then all my time was just
spent going to Disney World
for, like, everything.
-Yeah.
-Like, 'cause what
other activities?
Go to the grocery store?
No, I'm going up to Epcot.
-Now, did you ultimately --
have you exhausted your joy
of Disney World,
having spent so much time there?
-No, no.
I love that place.
I went to Disney World --
Before that,
I had been one time.
I went with my dad.
He took me to Disney World.
It was just me and him,
and my dad was a little older,
so he was kind of tired,
so we'd go on the rides.
But he'd be like, "I'm going to
sit down on this bench.
You enjoy."
And there were so many times
where he was sticking to me,
like, "Don't be late.
Come back at this time.
Otherwise, trouble."
And I would be late so often.
But then on the way back,
I think I learned my lesson.
On the flight back,
we were at the airport
getting ready to fly back,
and I was like,
"I'm gonna go get some water.
I'll be right back."
"Don't be late."
And I was like, "I won't be.
I promise."
Went and I was
reading a magazine.
Uh-oh!
Came back, we missed the flight.
[ Laughter ]
So all the lessons of the week
were for nothing.
-I just think you wanted
to stay at Disney World.
-Yeah, I was like,
"Let's get an apartment here."
-Thanks so much for being here.
It's always a pleasure
to see you.
You guys, that's Sam Richardson.
New episodes of "The Afterparty"
are available Fridays
on Apple TV+.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."